j'espère vous m'entendez bien eux
comme on vient de vous le dire je suis
chercheur au cnrs et ce soir je voudrais
vous parler
hirsch j'espère vous êtes nombreux ici à
aimer comme moi la nature je vois
quelques hochements de tête ça m'arrange
parce que mon propos ce soir va tourner
essentiellement autour de la nature
je pense que certains d'entre vous aime
partir la découvrir cette nature en se
baladant ou en voyageant et bien ce soir
je vous propose de voyager un petit peu
justement pour tenter de la redécouvrir
cette nature peut être sous un autre
angle
on est bien d'accord la nature elle est
belle mais elle n'est pas que bell et on
peut le voir avec ces images derrière
moi elle est également diverses et
probablement que sa beauté tient à sa
diversité diversité oui vous allez plein
de copieurs aussi la nature plein
d'imitateur moi on m'a toujours dit
depuis que j'étais tout petit que c'est
vraiment pas bien de copier mais je me
demande si on m'a pas dit un petit peu
n'importe quoi
regardez ces trois organismes juste tous
les trois d'une stratégies adaptatives
dit d'imitation qu'on appelle le
mimétisme
regardez par exemple cet insecte je ne
sais pas si vous le voyez ici vous voyez
c'est un phasme qui en imitant l'aspect
d'une brindille réussi à se camoufler et
réussi comme ça à échapper à ses
prédateurs oiseaux ou rongeurs cette
araignée avec son habillage de frelons
elle elle réussit comme ça à passer plus
ou moins inaperçu vis-à-vis de ses
proies et ça lui permet de doubler le
nom de ces captures tout en restant au
centre de sa toile et puis enfin cette
cette orchidée sauvage en imitant
l'aspect de certains insectes va réussir
à les attirer et les insectes croyant
venir copuler en fait vont tout
simplement polliniser lafleur alors
qu'est ce qu'on a envie de dire en
voyant ces images est ce que ces
organismes sont de vilains copieurs ou
tout simplement est ce qu'on voit ici le
résultat d'une ingénieuse nature je
pense que vous voyez où je veux en venir
copier imiter finalement ce n'est pas
forcément une mauvaise chose surtout
quand il s'agit de la nature déjà au
xviiie siècle un écrivain allemand
s'appelait gotthold lessing disait que
tout et mutations de la nature n'est pas
ne peut pas être un défaut et je pense
qu'on peut même aller encore plus loin
en disant que imiter la nature peut même
procuré des bienfaits à son imitateur
on vient de le voir ça permet à certains
de se reproduire à d'autres de se
nourrir à d'autres de se protéger
et pis mais parlons de nous un petit peu
tous ici on est des imitateurs en
puissance déjà tout petit enfant
c'est en imitant nos parents et notre
entourage qu'on a appris à marcher qu'on
a appris à parler et puis petit à petit
qu'on a appris à interagir avec nos
congénères en bonne intelligence au sein
de sociétés organisées c'est en imitant
nos sportifs préférés
un conte s'améliorant sport c'est en
imitant nos pères qu'on s'améliore dans
notre travail qu'on améliore et
diversifier nos compétences certains
font même de limitation leur métier et
en général on adore ça pour se divertir
on peut également imiter la nature est
ce qu'il ya des pêcheurs de truites ici
vous savez que les pêcheurs de truites
prépare pour bon nombre d'entre eux
mêmes leur a pas ou l'eure l'eure et
leur donne l'aspect d'un insecte pour
attirer le poisson
vous avez tous en tête l'image de la
pêche à la mouche les naturalistes
ornithologues qui aime aller observer
les oiseaux dans leur milieu naturel
bon nombre d'entre eux savent imiter le
chant des oiseaux pour attirer les
oiseaux qu'ils veulent observer et s'ils
ne savent pas imiter ses champs ils
peuvent disposer d' à pau est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu au delà de se
divertir on pourra en demander encore un
petit peu plus à la nature voici janine
benyus derrière moi une scientifique
américaine qui a théorisé vers la fin
des années 90 tout l'intérêt qu'aurait
l'homme a intégré dans ses conceptions
tout le génie de la nature une idée dont
léonard de vinci a probablement été le
pionnier c'est ce qu'on appelle le
biomimétisme où le bio inspiration le
biomimétisme ça veut dire s'inspirer de
la nature pour créer et concevoir de
nouveaux systèmes de nouvelles solutions
technologiques de nouvelles solutions
thérapeutiques et tout ça en respectant
la biosphère et la biodiversité
alors on va prendre un exemple tout de
suite pour qu'on voit bien tous de quoi
on parle
je vous ai dit qu'on allait voyager
alors choisissons le domaine de
l'aéronautique
on va retourner au xvème siècle et on va
encore parler de léonard de vinci qui
élabore les premiers plans des machines
volantes battant des ailes comme des
oiseaux il va pas allé jusqu'à
construire ces machines mais ces
machines vont tout de même permettre un
général de napoléon en 1802 réussir à
voler en battant des ailes sur près de
300 mètres tout en se cassant finalement
qu'une seule jambe à l'atterrissage un
peu plus tard au 19e siècle clément ader
le premier qui a réussi à faire voler
des objets plus lourd que l'air est bien
lui pour réussir à mettre au point ces
prototypes et c'est en fait inspirée des
ailes des chauves souris
et puis plus près de nous vous avez
peut-être remarqué comme on le voit ici
que de plus en plus l'extrémité des
ailes des avions est pourvue des lettres
comme celle ci en fait ces ailettes
réduisent l'envergure globale de
l'appareil limite les forces de
frottement avec l'air et par là-même
finalement facilite la pénétration dans
l'air de l'avion et réduisent le coût
énergétique du vol réduisent la
consommation en kérosène et ainsi que la
pollution en même temps alors bien sûr
c'est pas aussi efficace que ne plus
avoir d'avion du tout mais c'est
vraiment un bon pas dans le bon dans le
bon sens et il ya fort à parier que tout
ça vienne du biomimétisme
regardez ces ailettes sont directement
inspirés des régies des rémiges primaire
des grands rapaces ses plumes qui pour
améliorer le vol de l'oiseau se replient
vers le haut comme ça dans certains
moments de son vol est finalement à
l'avenir on pense que les avions
ressembleront de plus en plus à des
oiseaux alors je voudrais pas multiplier
les exemples où l'inspiration de la
nature est de la technologie mais je
vais quand même en vous en citer comme
ça quelques-uns qui me paraissent
relativement marquants des inspirations
qui permettent d'améliorer
de prod2 produire des économies
énergétiques pensez par exemple au bec
profil et du martin pêcheur qui a
inspiré le design du nez du tgv japonais
pour une meilleure pénétration dans
l'air pensez aux termites hier en
afrique dans l'auto la ventilation leur
permet de rester constamment à une
température de 25 30 degrés alors
quelles que soient les températures
extérieures qui peuvent monter jusqu'à
50 en journée et descendre jusqu'à zéro
la nuit il ya des inspirations de la
nature qui nous amène aussi du confort
penser à la feuille de lotus la folie de
lotus elle présente la particularité de
repousser si efficacement les molécules
d'eau que l'eau ruisselle à sa surface
en entraînant toute molécule de
poussière qui pourraient s'y trouver
et bien la feuille de lotus a inspiré
des revêtements autonettoyants pour les
vitrages par exemple et puis enfin il ya
des inspirations qui aident à améliorer
notre sécurité
et là je vais vous parler du bombyx du
mûrier le papillon du ver à soie alors
lui il a des antennes absolument
extraordinaire qui lui permettent de
détecter un partenaire sexuel à
plusieurs centaines de mètres de lui
si on remet ça à notre échelle c'est
comme si nous ici à paris on pouvait
détecter une personne susceptible de
nous plaire et qui serait en train de se
promener en ce moment à versailles
c'est à dire à 20 kilomètres d'ici et
bien en s'inspirant des antennes de ce
papillon
on a réussi on réussit maintenant à
détecter des explosifs
par exemple ont réussi à détecter 800
molécules seulement de tnt diluée dans
10 millions de milliards de molécules
d'air c'est à dire que ça c'est mille
fois mieux que ce qu'on réussissait à
faire avant d'imiter cet animal est
comme ça il ya des dizaines d'exemples
qu on pourrait citer où l'inspiration de
la nature permet d'améliorer la
technologie de la rendre plus
performante et plus économe mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse vraiment dans mes
recherches c'est la santé et je vous
présente ici à gauche claude bernard le
père de la biologie et de la médecine
expérimentale et à droite
auguste krog prix nobel de physiologie
et médecine
le premier a travaillé plutôt dans la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle le second
dans la première moitié du xxème et bien
tous deux ont développé finalement la
même idée que je résume par cette phrase
ici la solution pour résoudre un
problème de biologie ou de médecine se
cachent forcément chez une espèce
animale
bien sûr aujourd'hui on sait qu'ils
avaient raison et au delà des animaux on
sait aussi que les solutions se cacher
d'autres types d'organismes chez des
micro-organismes chez des plantes par
exemple la nature elle est pleine de
solutions pour les chirurgiens par
exemple penser à la moule qui s'accroche
coûte que coûte à son rocher dans l'eau
quoi qu'il arrive et bien là réussi cet
exploit en produisant une substance qui
est aujourd'hui l'une des cols les plus
puissantes connu une colle qui n'est pas
polluante et qui permet des sutures
absolument parfaite en chirurgie humaine
un autre exemple vers de vase ou le
verre art et nicole pour ceux qui
connaissent alors lui il est pas capable
de respirer quand il se retrouve à marée
basse
et pourtant il est capable de survivre
dans cet état là pendant plusieurs
heures
comment fait-il des équipes ont réussi à
montrer en l'étudiant qu'il possédait
une hémoglobine dont le poouvoir
oxygénant est 50 fois plus fort que
notre hémoglobine à nous c'est à dire
que son hémoglobine entraîne avec elle
davantage de molécules d'oxygène ce qui
lui permet de supporter toutes ces
heures de marée basse et bien à partir
de l'hémoglobine de ce ver on a réussi à
développer une hémoglobine universel
universel ça veut dire qu'elle est
transposable à tout le monde et en plus
cette hémoglobine permet de bien mieux
conserver les greffons par exemple la
nature c'est aussi une énorme pharmacie
vous savez que bon nombre de médicaments
pour bon nombre de médicaments
les principes actifs ont été découverts
dans la nature dans des arbustes dans
des arbres dans des fleurs dans
desvenain d'animaux par exemple
et tous ces médicaments là aujourd'hui
permettent de traiter des maladies aussi
diverses que le paludisme le diabète
l'hypertension artérielle ou même dans
certains cas certains cancers on est en
hiver je suis sûr que certains d'entre
vous ont déjà eu quelques petites
infections
et vous avez probablement déjà pris des
antibiotiques
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
les antibiotiques ce que vous savez d'où
ils viennent on peut retourner à
l'antiquité puisque à l'antiquité on
avait déjà découvert comment traiter
certaines infections avec des
moisissures et bien dans ces moisissures
il y à des micro-organismes qui
produisent des molécules qui sont
capables de s'attaquer à d'autres
micro-organismes et ça ce sont les
molécules antimicrobiennes et les
molécules antibiotiques et depuis
l'antiquité on a redécouvert de
nombreuses molécules aux propriétés
antimicrobiennes dans bon nombre
d'organismes par exemple dans des
champignons
ce qui me permet de citer la célèbre
pénicilline mais on en a retrouvé
également chez dans d'autres types
d'organismes par exemple dans des
papillons ou même récemment dans des
oiseaux alors là on se rapproche un
petit peu de 2 ce qui m'intéresse moi
vraiment dans mes recherches c'est à
dire essayer de comprendre par quels
mécanismes certains animaux sont
capables de supporter des conditions qui
pour nous humains seraient extrême
un exemple à votre avis on a ici un
manchot royal sur l'archipel de crozet
à votre avis comment a réussi c'est
oiseaux qui a seul un cube et son oeuvre
pendant près de trois semaines tout en
gardant sa température corporelle élevé
comme d'habitude et bien comment at il
fait pour maintenir en parfaite état ce
qui lui restait de nourriture dans
l'estomac pour pouvoir comme on le voit
sur la photo s'en servir le régurgiter
pour nourrir son poussin à l'éclosion et
bien en étudiant ce phénomène on a
découvert que bien sûr il a arrêté tous
les processus de digestion il a diminué
la motilité gastrique c'est à dire tous
les mouvements que son estomac aurait pu
faire il a maintenu dans son estomac un
ph élevé et on a découvert qu'il a
également produit au niveau de l'estomac
une molécules aux propriétés
antimicrobiennes en effet on a montré
que cette molécule qui porte aujourd'hui
le joli nom de ce pénis in 1 est capable
de s'attaquer à des micro organismes
tels que des jus de champignons
aspergillus où la bactérie staphylocoque
doré qui sont responsables de graves
infections chez l'homme
reste aujourd'hui à s'inspirer de cette
molécule pour développer et tester des
nouveaux médicaments
et puis
encore un exemple qui celui là vraiment
pour le couvent à me tenir à coeur
puisque au centre de mes recherches
depuis plusieurs années l'ours brun
cet animal est absolument fantastique à
plus d'un titre
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous parler de
sa capacité à rester tapi dans sa
tanière sans manger sans boire sans même
bouger pendant près de la moitié de
l'année sans quasiment perdre de masse
et de force musculaire nous si on reste
sans manger pendant de longues périodes
où si on reste inactif pendant de
longues périodes on va forcément perdre
du muscle et pire la perte de muscles
chez l'homme et le manque d'activité
il a été montré qu'elles sont
directement responsables de certaines
pathologies comme l'obésité comme le
diabète comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires par exemple
aujourd'hui l'om s arrange le manque
d'activité physique au quatrième rang
des risques des facteurs de risque de
mortalité dans le monde
aujourd'hui le manque d'activité
physique du autant que la cigarette est
bien en étudiant la biologie la
physiologie de l'hibernation chez l'ours
on cherche comment soigner l'homme et
parmi divers mécanismes que nous avons
déjà découvert
nous avons notamment montré que
certaines molécules qui circule dans le
sens des ours pas n'importe quand en
hiver sont capables de protéger du
muscle humain il nous reste aujourd'hui
à identifier à isoler ces molécules pour
pouvoir tester de nouvelles thérapies
alors je vous avais dit qu'on allait re
découvrir la nature au début de cette
présentation
sa richesse sa diversité sa beauté vous
voyez que sa beauté elle tient aussi
dans le fait que c'est une
extraordinaire source de connaissances
et de progrès
et quand on y réfléchit c'est peut-être
qu'une demi surprise parce que
finalement la nature elle a eu des
millions d'années pour évoluer pour
s'adapter à tous les changements
climatiques aux attentes à tous les
environnements possible pour tester et
ne retenir que les solutions qui
marchent et tout ça on le redécouvre
aujourd'hui avec le biomimétisme à
l'avenir peut-être
imiter la nature ça pourrait bien se
révéler finalement une stratégie gagnant
gagnant pour améliorer notre technologie
et notre santé comme on vient de le
discuter
mais mieux connaître la biologie de
nombreuses espèces ça va nous aider
aussi à mieux savoir comment les
protéger
comment les conserver et donc à mieux
lutter contre l'érosion de la
biodiversité
donc ce que je vous propose c'est
d'essayer de protéger la biodiversité
cette extraordinaire encore une fois
source d'idées source d'innovation
étudions un maximum d'espèces et
finalement je pourrais résumer tout ce
que je veux dire en paraphrasant une
citation qui encore une fois est
attribué à léonard de vinci apprenons de
la nature c'est vraiment là que se
trouve notre futur et je vous remercie
litres
[Applaudissements]